vous avez les yeux les mains d'un homme
violent
je le sais parce que je connais des
hommes jeunes qu'est ce qu'un homme
violent peut vraiment croire qu'il
trouvera la paix mais si vous avez
besoin de quelque chose que vous êtes là
toute la nuit j'avais voulu en fait le
double zéro
oui je suis là toute la nuit je croyais
que vous étiez le réceptionniste
réceptionniste barman guardian nuit
propriétaire
[Musique]
dans cet endroit depuis combien de temps
environ un an c'est un ami qui m'a cédé
on a entendu dire qu'avec pas d'amis
j'en ai plus je suis en train de
m'extraire
une situation très compliquée parce que
tu que c'est de l'argent de quelqu'un
d'autre je ne vois pas de cette manière
mais quelqu'un voit ainsi tu sais qui je
suis vous donner un genre et toi tandjan
way le genre à vouloir rester en vie
sentiment que je parte sans savoir ce
qui se passe parce que je sais vraiment
pas ce qui se passe ici n'est pas dans
la confiance il faudrait que je fasse
confiance et alors que tu me fais pas
confiance tu veux mourir
il ya quelque chose qui me gêne chez toi
c'est toi qui est à l'origine de tout ça
tu veux que je te dise que je suis
désolé
je suis pas celui que tu crois tu ne
veux pas l'être vitu les
[Musique]
je suppose que tu avais un flingue dans
ton cercle mais j'en ai un mais je suis
tombée sur le couteau